uh good evening everyone seven o'clock
so we'll get started
welcome everyone to uh this meeting of
the overview scrutiny panel on the 30th
of May
2023.
I'd like to welcome all the new faces
here this evening and some very familiar
ones
uh just a few items I need to go through
first with the Five Alarm procedures if
the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices down the main
staircase opposite the lifts in the
foyer assembly in Hawley Square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise you when it's deemed safe to
return to the chamber
would everyone please present ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silence and they are not used to make
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress please note this meeting
has been live streamed for members of
the public the meeting will also be
recorded and we will be subsequently
broadcast on the internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
nope so we'll move on
I've not received any requests to speak
under rule 20.1
I don't think we've got any speaking no
okay do we are we all aware what 20.1 is
does that come up in the training
yeah okay excellent
okay apologies for absence any apologies
for absence councilor Curry
apologies for absence from councilor
Rupa farooqi and councilor Christian
bright
thank you
are there any Declarations of Interest
and no no declarations winter so to
approve the minutes of the overview and
security panel meeting I held on the
14th of March 2023 a copy of the agenda
is in the pack uh I know there's only a
few people here that were at that
meeting so I can either
proposer
councilor Moore and a seconder council
Austin thank you all members are great
thank you okay
sure
what will be happening now about the
report that the working group led by
councilor Curry
um
and also we never got
feedback from the previous cabinet on
the work of the working group that you
led yourself and I'm wondering if
perhaps as chair you might be willing to
write to the leader and cabinet and ask
how they're going to follow those two
reports up please thank you
I have already discussed with Charles
about that yet so the the working group
party that we were worked on with with
Council Curry that shared that hasn't
gone to Cabinet yet which I'm not sure
if it's going at the next cabinet
meeting I think it'd be up to um
is it up to you Charles to four six
three cabinet
yeah we need to take it to Cabinet yes
chair and all I need to do now is was to
wait for the new admination to settle
down and I would want to imagine the
June meeting will be too early most
likely it will be the July one the 27th
that answers that question sorry carry
on and might I comment that it's very
encouraging to see that uh town and
Parish councilors have been invited to
certain of the training which is one was
one of the recommendations I don't think
all of the training I think there's
still some things that they would like
to be able to access that they haven't
done yet but it's a really good step
forward and we'd like to say thanks to
democratic services for doing that yeah
I agree and I'm sure we'll all support
Alan or Council Curry when it comes to
cabinet
so it was an excellent review which
definitely needs Taking forward this new
Administration uh Council Patman uh
thanks chair sorry I'm a bit slow on the
Declaration of interest uh just to
declare an interest on the housing
performance report yep I work for
housing provider so there may be a
conflict of interest in there okay
and
on the topic of the wet coaster waste
review yeah I was going to bring that up
in the next item because I think
yeah okay so that's moving on to our
agenda for this evening so item four on
the agenda to establish the overview and
scrutiny panel work program for 2023 to
24 so I'm going to ask members to
identify topics for the panel's work
program so
members so hands up straight away to
cancel Austin
he could just take
just taking this because
most of us have attended the training
over the last couple of weeks uh on
overview screen you know you attended
the same one that I did and certainly I
have realized that the scope and the
responsibilities of the scrutiny panel
are much wider than I had realized and I
am concerned that the way that we are
scoring topics to go into the work
program feels to me to be a lot more
restrictive than I understood the
trainer gave a scope for in the session
that I attended
we appear to be looking at
our own activities much more than
broader topics that affect
our community and it would be good to to
see that we had the opportunity to do
both I realized our time is limited uh
but that the way that the scoring setup
seems to work feels to me like it will
bring us back down all the time to Let's
scrutinize this decision that's coming
up in cabinet rather than let's have a
look at big issues that affect our
community so the big issue is I would
like to throw forward are and I realized
that we won't be able to deal with all
of them but in terms of topics I'd like
us to look at the cost of living
and debt and related matters Food Bank
use Etc
I'd like us to look at health and
well-being
and I'd like us to look sorry
I just want to keep up
sorry and I'd like us to look at another
topic that I've totally forgotten but
I'll come back to you yeah thanks uh
Council so I I take on board what you
say because I I always understood it to
be that we're we're scrutinizing exactly
cabinet decisions exactly I know this is
over and above obviously matters that
are coming up on the forward Planet I've
wrote down a quote that the Train on I
can't remember his name now Paul or
something another he said scrutiny has
the power to in-law to look at anything
which affects our area or inhabitants
exactly exactly and we've got so many
big issues affecting our community at
the moment that I do think that we
should perhaps be trying to raise our
eyes a bit above above just what sure
and another point from Charles earlier
is that you know the reviews we can only
do one at a time because of course
officer time we've only got limited
amount of Officer time so we have to be
careful to make sure but matters ways of
scoring like you get a higher score if
it's been on the list for a long time
well maybe it's been on the list for a
long time because actually it wasn't
really very relevant or maybe something
that's coming up like the cost of living
is more urgent so we I think we have to
have a bit of flexibility on that don't
we yeah absolutely
um I think councilor green your home
assistant
yeah I think we have to be a bit careful
about
attempted to scrutinize things that are
Way Beyond tdc's
um absolutely I think you know when
we've got to scrutinize things that we
can make recommendations and and as
you'd make a difference and make a
change I think one thing that came up
with the training was dentistry and I
think we can do a screen we we can't we
have no influence on what happens in
dentists on the area you know we can't
we can make recommendations but nobody
will take any notice of us
yeah absolutely sure counselor Perry
I think we should certainly invite the
members of the cabinet I'll go on to
Cabinet presentations or presentations I
think we do scrutiny work review program
topics first and then we'll look at um
present presentations that we're going
to have at each meeting and in a moment
the one thing that has been impressed of
me
is the problem of how of her
affordability
yeah if we could look at
how that impacts on people in Janet and
what if anything TDC can do sure okay
thank you okay
thank you chair I think a a real basic
topic that we could discuss and look at
is the issue of broken bins around the
ward it it affects most Wards some Wards
more than others but this is an ongoing
problem that not only affects residents
but it affects councilors case work and
it affects our Frontline workers as well
just a missing bin lead causes added
problems as we all know uh so I just
think this is a basic topic that we
could look at and maybe look at some
type of Bin amnesty I know the council
used to repair bins I don't think that's
on offer anymore so most of the
residents are asked to pay 55 pounds for
a new bin when in fact that lid has come
off during collection and they just
haven't reported it so I think this is
something we could uh definitely look
thank you Chet um and I apologize I feel
like I may be uh putting topics and
potential presentations into one so I'm
just going to roll with a list of things
that I feel are of Interest not just to
us as a committee but also our residents
as well
um and I feel that even though uh the
reviews of certain ones that I will say
are ongoing I still think that I know
they will be coming up later on this
year and it'll be good to have them be
called into this committee and somewhere
on our agenda
um so I would quite like at some
presentation around the parking charges
review that's going on
um I think that's quite an important
subject especially for our district I
would like us to have on uh somewhere on
the agenda a review around the Winter
Gardens for us to be kept up to date on
that and see what's been coming out with
the work that's going on with that
um I would like us to also
be involved or have the review of the
toilet strategy when that comes up and
of course I think members will know that
that's a strategy that's close to my
heart
that I'm we'll see how that turns out
and lastly for me
um I think that as a topic that is
incredibly uh well topical for our area
and Incredibly important for our area
whether you're for or against but I do
think that Madison airport should be
called into over a year scrutiny um
and I think that we should invite Tony
freudman to do a presentation
um in front of overview and scrutiny
thank you yeah I'll come on to the
presentations in a minute I'll just get
some
looking at the broader issues one of the
things I'd like to see us review is how
enforcement takes place particularly in
terms of planning
there seems to be no
um standard that's met and it depending
on the issue and the complexity of it uh
there's a I've heard
prior to being elected as well from a
huge number of people with very real
concerns about lack of action even when
enforcement notices are in place sure
um this afternoon I've had an email from
cliffson Parish Council regarding
illegal dumping of waste on Farmland
they've tried five times to get an
answer and and haven't received a
response so without getting into the
individual case it's a big issue and
it's growing and it's starting to cause
real frustration in the community and I
think perhaps we need to look at that as
what can be done to ensure that there's
a set of protocols that work in a fair
to all I know it's come up before in
questions at Council I always think the
dance has always been staffing issues I
think well there's also the matter of
course because when it comes to waste
and minerals the the KCC are often the
um the planning Authority and so on a
prime case in point is the constant
situation with brex at the Port you know
who is responsible for it why do they
have to in in every other area of the
country that they operate they've had to
have planning permission for batching
plan and for industrial processes and
yet in fact we seem to think that it's
it's permitted development you can do
what you like and there's absolutely no
enforcement or joined up thinking we
cannot get straight answers either from
KCC or TDC and that's something that I
think and I know the public particularly
wants some answers on them we should be
giving a clear position on that so
perhaps we could somebody scrutiny to
what's going on is that two topics then
blending enforcement and the port is
that two discipline
they're connected inextricably because
of the fact that that industrialization
is a huge issue it's been an issue for
the best part of a decade now and there
are no straight answers on this whose
responsibility is it why has there not
been planning applications and planning
enforcement and in fact environmental
enforcement because there are breaches
of the environmental conditions down
there Sean and open past history
so I am talking about enforcement as a
as an area in general be it building
enforcement planning enforcement or sure
yeah and clarity as to who and which
authority is actually responsible for
that sure I can't take because you're
not part of the panel you can email me
your topics in if you like well
no sorry it was just to express
um support for a previous point if
members were considering bringing topics
forward that they thought had breadth to
them effectively
um you'll know from previously although
I think that obviously the subjects have
to link to what we we do as a council
I've always argued that
we have greater breadth in terms of
multi-agency involvement within this
panel than maybe we've used so I just
wanted to encourage people to bring
things forward because I can say that
cabinet would be supportive of looking
at things thank you in a multi-agency
context I think it's funny so that
multi-agency because I had an email from
one of your colleagues in in on your
party saying um
she's wondering if the council would
consider taking on a review of how TDC
Works in a multi-agency way we already
have working relationships with the
police such as Community safety and
multi-agency task force however there
seems to be a little way of multi-agency
working in other agencies such as social
services and education when it comes to
housing
yeah we're often involved with the same
families and I I don't know I've not
never been involved in housing so I
don't know if there's something already
there with that I don't know yeah I'd
agree with that statement I'm not sure
if that's I love housing therefore I
think it connects to everything
exclusively review topic always that's
something that you want to take away as
a policy that you might want to set up I
can do both I think OV and scrutiny is
very useful in that it's the public face
of our discussions so okay
thank you chair oh sorry I've lost my
glasses well I've left them somewhere so
I've got these they're on off I I really
think one of the most critical things
going forward is we mustn't forget we
mustn't forget the uh the lessons that
that we've been given through the
independent monitoring officers action
plan it's not a document that should be
put away and ticked it's been achieved
so I'd certainly like to see and a
regular update on the independent
monitor officers action plan
particularly the implementation of the
review of birth 4-5 in light of the fact
we have a number of large projects
including on the port I mean one of the
one of the key failings there was it was
a failure of TDC to actually set well I
don't think we have a project management
policy for big projects that needs
addressing straight away and hopefully
it's being done as I speak but also we
didn't have a project management team
and certainly I'd like to see the
project management team for the two lots
of Luft spending both in Margate and in
in in Ramsgate given the fact we still
have a a birth four or five which is not
operational and we don't know exactly
how much it cost us I think it's that is
a key thing that we need to be ongoing
but also looking at the other uh the
other action points that the independent
monitor the imprint monitoring officer
suggested in that report we need to keep
an eye on that we're actually keeping
that document as a working document and
applying every aspect of as we as we
further move forward and improve uh we
due for a parking review and I can tell
you alongside housing and rubbish
parking is now is now is now in my world
is creating conflict between
particularly Builders Vans and residents
that sometimes are denied access on
their own streets because Builders won't
pay for the parking around the corner so
I certainly think the parking review is
a key thing and I hope stakeholders will
will be given a voice including
residents because residents are coming
up with some really good ideas on how we
can solve some of these problems not
just for residents but for visitors to
the area as well and our local Builders
I'd also like to to put housing there
I still nobody's explained if somebody
could explain how the government worked
out our housing numbers and if anybody's
read the document that TDC actually
commissioned in in 2021 where our
population is projected to increase by
10 up to 2040 then I'm not really sure
why we have 17 100 houses with an extra
four thousand my concern is housing
numbers the type of housing the nature
of the housing that's being built and
also the location of the housing uh I
you know we we desperately need social
housing so built into that is how do the
big developers manage to downgrade their
30 social housing to 15 when our overall
desperate need is for cheap affordable
rented and purchased and the other thing
is air quality which ties in with ties
in with uh ties in with uh really what
what what's already been spoken about on
the port I still remain quite angry and
frustrated about the environmental
impact assessment where dust monitoring
was done a thousand meters behind the
houses that are within 325 meters of
that Port
two days ago we've had North easterly
winds I visibly saw sand leaving that
site now residents are reporting dust in
the houses it could just be dust off the
sand but until somebody with the right
equipment and the right experience
monitors this dust we don't know whether
we're exposing our residents to harmful
levels of dust and it links in with what
council Austin said about the health
impacts some we need to look at how some
of the things that we do as a council
could considerably impact on the health
and in some cases the considerably poor
health of some of our residents already
so are the the action plan of the Imo's
action plan parking review housing
numbers type and and location and air
quality be the thing comes into them
thank you chair thank you councilor wing
I
cancel patterns before you I'll come
back to you
uh thank you chair um I would like to
see uh fly tip in and abandoned vehicles
um kind of scrutinize really
um we're going to see an increase in fly
tipping with the closure of waste and
recycling centers and I think that's
gonna have a huge impact on us as a
local Authority and we're already seeing
a huge impact of large Vehicles
abandoning Council car Parks which means
we can't actually do anything about it
under current agreements legislation so
that'd be good if we can get that on on
the agenda thank you thank you
I remember the last thing which was it
links with some of the things that have
been mentioned actually it was it was a
review of the impacts on us as a council
of Tourism that are that are negative
and how we can address them so things
like
um the impact of airbnbs uh the the
negative assisting from the positive
impact of having more accommodation
available for visitors uh parking
obviously visitor parking how we can
handle that better
Etc uh the possibility of a tourist tax
all those sorts of issues around our
visitor economy where we might actually
be able to handle things better if we
thought about them in a more joined up
way
I I totally agree I think um Airbnb
could have a totally review of a review
on its own I think I've just been in the
news again recently I think Herman
Margate talking about it the other day
and you know we I mean that's something
that funny Council can have have a
decision on and can change things and
maybe we need to look at it whether it's
having the impact that people say or
whether it's a positive thing or
negatively I don't know but maybe that's
a review on its own John
I'd like to support what said about the
impact of Airbnb I'm very cautious about
any form of Taxation and has been the
party that we should be however the
system I believe is being abused because
um if a property is left for more than I
think it's 90 days what's happening is
the owners are flipping it over to
business rates and then claiming
business rates relief so we lose all of
that Revenue you've only got to have 500
airbnbs and there's a lot more than that
on this island for that to have a
serious impact on our revenues and also
to follow up on what council packman
said about the parking it is horrendous
when these party houses have half a
dozen Vehicles turn up for the weekend
and I'm surrounded by them where I live
personally
um and we just can't park on our own
land that we own because it is
absolutely swamped with people just
arriving parking really nearly and uh
with when we need controls on this
because the whole situation is getting
out of hand and there are some very very
serious arguments developing with people
so you know and if the the risk of of
serious anti-social Behavior because of
these people is
pretty high
thank you Council Davis anybody else got
any suggestions how's it going
I think the parking charges review I
think that's
yeah
of the whole thing I definitely needed
yeah especially where we come from in
birchington
right so one other thing that I um put
down was something that came up at
Council a little while ago it's about
grant funding and
um I think it was said that there are
lots of I think it was you yourself that
made the point where there's lots of
funding out there to be got but not
enough staff in the council and I'd just
like you know to have a look at that see
what we're missing out on especially
recently I think there was a petition
got up about Jackie Baker's the changing
rooms and I'm sure there's grant funding
out there from sport England or anyone
like you know football or fa or but you
know is anybody researching now sport
England Capital funding ended in March
it's no longer they don't have any more
capitalism but I just you know it'd be
good to look
what other funding funding streams that
we're missing out and I think I think
that came up before that yeah
Council Davis
um I can't remember exactly which
project it was due from but I am aware
that there was section 106 money that
should have been allocated and could
have been allocated to Jackie Bakers and
it was a former officer that advised me
of this
um and the state of the changing rooms
and everything up there was completely
unnecessary had but I'm going back
historically but and I will get
information for those that would be
interested on this but that's the other
thing I think that we need to look at is
where does what where how is section 106
money being applied
um at the moment Canterbury city council
for example are recruiting a specific
officer to manage section 106 money and
make recommendations as to how it's
spent and to ensure that it does come in
as we seem to have a black hole that
things just fall into and it allows you
know valid projects like like the Jackie
Baker's changing rooms to fall into the
disrepair where it becomes a massive
issue which it needn't have been had it
just been followed through on as I say
unfortunately I can't remember which
which project the 106 money that was
supposed to have gone into that came
from but
what are those things have a long long
list whether we get through them in the
next 12 months or no no I I don't know
sure counseling grants we
aware of one was uh that we the Escape
boarding governing body approached
directly the war wreck skate park people
and us and we tried to negotiate uh us
having a nominated officer and us
actually working up the bid I have
experience of uh of of of bringing in
850 000 pounds worth of Grants as my
previous role in in Charlton to keep our
mentoring Services going and Trisha
Council Austin has the experience of
sport England and we just found doors
slammed in our face that money was it
was there allocated ready for than it
and it was lost more recently the new
the new tenants on Spencer Square tennis
courts they've done a fabulous job if
you fancy a copper get into Spencer
Square it's lovely there is lawn tennis
money available to refurbish tennis
courts dover's courts are already being
actioned but we had to step in again to
try and push off officers to hack
actually allow one of the the the tenant
the leaseholders to actually help fill
the application in I think that's been
pushed over the line and we will see
some of our tennis courts resurfaced and
I do get it that we've got officers that
have just got way too much to do but you
also have experts out in the communities
that are more than prepared to actually
work alongside offices to make sure we
don't miss out on that money because I
believe than it's missing out on huge
amounts of grant money given our
deprivation and that was exactly the
point I was like no one's ever going to
criticize offices we all know they do
fantastic work but it is purely officer
time and and shortage of Staff yeah sure
okay moving on so um councilor yes sorry
I've been listening intently
um there are a couple of others would
like to maybe consider and they're quite
important to both all the communities
they are the lifts
uh which we have constant problems with
and accessibility to our beaches for
people with disabilities and a point in
question I think in the last cabinet
previous cabinet we were told that there
was money aside to relay a new walkway
on Viking Bay ready for the season and
the season is imminent but I'm speaking
to one of the cabinet members they
didn't see any anything coming forward
from the officers about the funding or
the costing of that so I don't think the
money will be available for that and we
need to be reassured because we were
told categorically that this would be
done before the season so people had
access from one side of the bay to the
other and it still hasn't come to
fruition
okay thanks councilman
I mean going back to um the training I
remember the um the trainer saying we
can do a screen review in a day or some
of these subjects can can can be quite
quick and I think to look at because I
know the ones that we worked on took
some months you know to gather the
evidence and speak to different people
so I think some of them can be done
quite quickly and um so we'll look at
those and and see which ones fit the
criteria okay so moving on to cabinet or
not cabinet presentations but
presentations at each uh scrutiny
meeting going forward so we need to
decide who we'd like to invite when we'd
like to invite them in what order we'd
like to invite them I think personally I
think we should invite the leader of the
council first for him to come along and
give us his vision
for the next four years and and and see
what what what's happening there so I
think personally next group to me we
should invite Council ever if everyone
agrees Okay so
and then I'll leave it up to you how we
want to
who we want to or when we want to invite
everyone else I think going through the
cabinet members I think we need to
invite them one at a time whether we do
them in order or over the next five
meetings or we want to invite other
people and mix it up a little bit I've
got councilor cut with his hand up
uh just on the cabinet inviting cabinet
members
um I think that it would obviously make
most sense for us to invite them when
they're in particular reviews that
they're in charge of come about
um so that we don't kind of
double book them as such that they come
to to one and their review is released a
month later and then we have to invite
them back because we've asked for a
certain topic to be discussed so if we
can kind of have a look or have an idea
when those reviews are likely to be
published and then we can then set our
own agendas around when to invite those
company members in as well I think that
would probably be be best yeah sure so
we'll start with Council ever and then
we'll be wait till the next meeting
decide who we won or is there somebody
you want to invite particularly outside
of the council to give a presentation
councilor Austin
does this link with our plans on the
forward plan because if we're going to
try and pull it together in that way
then we might want to look at the
forward plan topics and which cabinet
member is responsible and see if we can
do it like that I don't know if that
makes sense yeah absolutely yeah we can
there's going to be some elements for
forward plan that we're not interested
in talking to people in any greater
detail about but there are some like for
example air quality monitoring that
Council Wing mentioned but also
um my particular concern is the leveling
up funds and I would want to see ideally
really looking at the way that the
forward plan obviously involves leveling
up decisions at every cabinet meeting I
would want us to see a leveling up
report even if it's a written report at
every scrutiny meeting so that we can
have a look at where we are with things
most particularly are we meeting the
deadlines are we fitting the time scales
that we're that we're committed to are
we spending the money that the rate
we're supposed to be doing because it
has an enormous impact on our
communities but it also has a huge
impact on our budget we're not limited
just to cabinet members we cannot yeah
[Laughter]
where is the project management team and
the policy because if if we that was one
of the reviews that came out of birth
four or five I mean surely before you
begin a project you need a policy and
then you need you need the team and
that's exactly one of the the the pieces
of information that Christine Parker put
in that births four or five review so it
would I'd quite like to know who's in
the team and that could include outside
experts I'd like to know who's in the
team and what's what's their specialist
input into that area particularly on the
port because we have a a number of key
areas we've got the hotel we've got the
green the green Hub we've got uh we've
got the uh the ferry the fish aspect and
then we've also got this potential
expansions of Brits that was mentioned
in the last which does concern me given
that historic lease which he's a
sweetheart lease
okay so I've got Council of it for the
first one and then a leveling up
presentation for the second one and they
can
bring all their people and we can ask
the questions yeah
yeah absolutely okay and then we can
decide going forward who want after that
so that's the next two meetings sort of
councilor Davis you've got your hand up
just a thought and and it's an area that
I know is of a lot of concern for people
we do seem to have moved into a new era
when it comes to unfortunately when it
comes to emergency decisions because
there are a series of emergency
decisions and I'm referring specifically
to birth four and five and how that was
handled
um at the time the emergency decision
was because nobody thought these births
were going to be about the barges would
be available well that's open to a lot
of discussion however uh those the barge
concerned has now been installed for 12
months purportedly because we had a
liability to bretts to provide them with
a barge in order for them to offload
brex can offload without a barge because
they've been doing it using a vessel
that discharges directly onto the key
side however 12 months after that birth
was installed there is still no
application for superstructure there is
no superstructure or infrastructure
structure whatsoever on it why is it
there and why was it an emergency
decision
um the expansion of Brits is part of the
leveling up I think that can those
questions
I'd question that actually chair if I
might because uh
no clue whatsoever about it the leveling
up funds are for specific projects
Brett's has been bolted on because we've
been told for the last
six years certainly that Brett's have no
plan to expand they've stated that
themselves to our MP and to various
groups and to this Council and in fact
it's a matter of record in this chamber
from a number of previous leaders that
Brits have no plans to expand and we've
had no dialogue with them or any
dialogue has said they have no plans to
expand it strikes me as somewhat
fortuitous that now we've gone through
this emergency acquisition process spent
millions of pounds on a birth that has
no equipment on it to offload they've
suddenly miraculously decided that they
want to expand thank you John
it's the questions to be put I mean yeah
it's okay but what I'm saying is within
our within our scrutiny yeah I would
like us to to perhaps look historically
at how emergency decisions have been
claimed and to ensure that we don't ever
return to those days of that's another
that's about yeah all those questions
you can ask how it all came around with
the Brett's expansion uh when when they
when they did sorry I'm not trying to
conflate the issue no absolutely it's
nothing we can talk okay tonight so okay
moving on so does anybody else got
anything to say about Council green
um
well we're talking about future
decisions
I took a look at the council's forward
plan yeah and the amount of information
about each item is minimal
it's almost impossible to know what some
of the decisions are going to be
and I've asked the officers to have a
look at whether it couldn't be improved
to include more information that's a
very good point yeah because I think
that that forward plan that I've seen
just lots of things about leveling up
that's going to come up at the cabinet
meeting and does no detail what those
are so yeah
uh Council Austin the matter that
there's a lot in this forward plan
that's got to be decided on extremely
quickly obviously because we've had the
Hiatus of the elections and the new
Council but that does mean that for
example the UK shared Prosperity fund
which we've heard almost nothing about
which as I understand is a fund to
replace European funds and allocated via
KCC I've asked repeatedly about this
funding I've heard nothing whatsoever
and now it's up for decision
consultation by the 15th of June so
we're too late to be able to call that
in and and assume about it I presume
that's going to Cabinet on June 15th so
we will have an opportunity we'll have
an opportunity to go and ask it and to
call it if you if you were so inclined
um but to have a look at that cabinet
certainly absolutely thanks sir anybody
else any ideas some more presentations
going forward well I I uh I didn't want
to get confused with the topics that I
raised so I would like to uh as a
presentation invite Tony freudman into
the presentation to this Council about
Manson airport
um and the arrangements around that
because I think it's important as I said
whether you are for or against it
because
it is a very topical issue and I think
it's only right that we scrutinize that
as a uh a committee here on this Council
okay thanks Council I mean yeah I don't
think he's ever given a presentation to
the council Council agree yeah I'm not
against that but I think we should wait
till after the court case before we do
it it will be after the court case
because we're we're already
when when is the next meeting
first of July so the next meeting is the
21st of July I've already got one set in
for the meeting after that so it's
probably going to be August September by
the time we get to that so it might not
even be important anyway or maybe the
biggest thing that's going to happen is
who knows
do all these things
uh Manson I just put down manston okay
any more ideas
or should we just leave it that for now
and move on otherwise we'll be here all
night
okay agenda item number five they're
building a safety act I call on Miss
Celio Sullivan to introduce the report
and welcome to the meeting silly thank
you chair
uh so the building safety act is a new
legislation that enhances the safety of
high-rise residential buildings it does
this by introducing new duties relating
to Fire and Building Safety it's
applicable to the council's tenant and
leaseholder services because this is the
team that manages the council's housing
stock
the council owns Six high-rise
residential buildings that fall into
scope of this new legislation
the ACT introduces the requirement of a
building safety case the building safety
case is all the information about how
the risk of fire spread and structural
safety of a building is managed and this
is needed to be submitted annually to
the new regulator for building safety it
also introduces two new roles and
responsibilities for landlords or
building owners these are the
accountable person and principal
accountable person and this report makes
a recommendation on who this should be
um some changes have needed to be made
within the team to accommodate the new
requirements the introduction of a new
post the building safety and compliance
manager allows the focus required to
ensure we are complying with the
requirements
a review of the fire risk assessment
policy because due to the building
safety act and changes in the regulatory
reform order 2005 for fire safety we
have needed to make amendments
and also enhances need to be made in our
current compliance database to hold all
new information required by the ACT
if that's okay as an introduction for
that if anyone has any questions
thank you uh selling so we've all had
the uh the report circulated
um the members have any questions or
comments they'd like to make counselor
green
yes thank you I wondered what other
resource implications of of taking this
on in terms of Staff Consultants
and you talk about a new database
and has the council received any
additional resources to carry out these
duties
thank you for that question
um so the we have had to or like I've
said before already we've had to
introduce a new role which is the
building safety and compliance manager
that is the only role that we've had to
introduce so far when it doesn't expand
our establishment I've managed to move
resources around within the team to
accommodate the new requirements
um we have had to
um approach and enhance the amount of
Consultants that we need to help us make
sure that we have become compliant and
also additional services that are needed
from Consultants as well
um we haven't received any further
funding for this
um we've the the budget to read that
I've calculated so far is approximately
50 000 pounds
um per year
so what will we stop doing in order to
do this
uh I've got no intention of stopping
anything
to do this
um
currently we are able to manage it
within the HRA budget
okay so councilman
uh obviously we've got Harbor Towers in
our world but oh yeah there's a there's
a there's a three or four more in in
Ramsgate that are even taller than
at Harbor Towers what will this look
like for residents and how will you
articulate any changes that are
necessary to residents
um so one of the main drivers for the
ACT is resident involvement and Resident
engagement because of course
um the way that residents use live and
behave within a building also poses a
big fire risk so we are developing a
kind of a bolt-on to our current
resident engagement strategy which is
for building safety
um through the tower block retrofit and
refurbishment project we have started
some consultation and we're also tagging
Building Safety into that
um we will be doing a special high-rise
resident Group which is only for only
for high-rise residents where we will
discuss with them building safety and
other matters that are important to them
because we know that living in high-rise
buildings is a lot different
we will also tailor our newsletters to
make sure that information for residents
that don't want to be as involved but
need to receive the information is put
is put out to them
also with um currently within the team
we are running a resident a council wide
for all of our residents the council
tenants a um a questionnaire which asks
for information demographic information
about all the residents that we have and
we will use that specifically in our
towel blocks to Target the more hard to
reach seldom herd groups so we can
tailor the information for those people
and to find out if they want to be
engaged in a way they want to be engaged
with us I'd just like to say thank you I
mean when I first got elected the first
time around I was bombarded with
complaints from Harbor Towers but since
we've taken it in-house and I did attend
the uh the open day I try and attend the
open days and and I'd like to thank the
teams for working really hard actually
things have definitely improved thank
you thank you counselor
Council green
you mentioned hard to reach groups are
you making any special arrangements for
leaseholders
um leaseholders are included in that as
they are residents of our buildings
and yes absolutely if if there are
groups of leaseholders that are harder
to reach we'll include those in the
people that we will be reaching out to
it's just that any decisions that are
made
has
greater impact on leaseholders because
they have to Fork out
thank you anybody else
any questions or comments they'd like to
make
okay so the panel is asked to review the
following recommendations the
recommendation is the name District
Council as the accountable person as
described in the building safety act
2022 and the recommendation to the name
the director of place which is Mr Bob
Porter as the principal accountable
person as described in the building
safety act 2022 do we all agree
thank you thank you sonny uh right
moving on to item number six which is
the quarter three and quarter four
2022-23 tenant and leaseholder
performance report I called upon again
miss Sally O'Sullivan to introduce
Liverpool
reports are overview and scrutiny and to
Cabinet today I've got Q3 and Q4 and
I'll give a brief overview of the
highlights and some of our lower points
for our compliance position that's the
landlord compliance most of our work
streams operate as business as usual and
hold a steady 100 compliance this
includes passenger lift inspections
water tank inspections Asbestos and gas
safety inspections
an area where we have been struggling
for some time is with our domestic
electrical safety certificate where we
have remained around 90 compliant for
most of this financial year
this indicates that we're coping with
the planned program but we are unable to
resolve a backlog so to address this we
procured a separate contractor to
deliver 100 completed certificates
and we meet with senior Mia's Personnel
on a weekly basis to monitor to progress
and to travel different solutions to
improve our statistics
we've seen steady progress with this
finishing Q3 at 91.93 and Q4 at 93.70 I
had a sneaky look at where we are today
and it's at 95.25 so it's really pleased
with that
another area where our stats aren't as
good as where we would like them to be
is with the fire risk assessment actions
Q3 total actions were 173 with 142 of
those being overdue and Q4 total actions
was 190 with 142 of those being to
overdue
during both quarters we closed out 247
that's in total over the six months
more actions added each quarter as we
complete our new fire risk assessments
on our buildings and we continue to
monitor these actions on a weekly basis
to ensure we're closing them out as fast
as we can
the ones that fall tend to fall overdue
are usually the actions that require
more major works for example if we find
that a roof is not is not hasn't doesn't
have the correct compartmentation in
there or if the fire doors need
replacing
for our operational performance Q3 saw
the usual trend
of a form in performance for our
partnering contractors and their
customer satisfaction this is due to a
spike in demand around that time of year
and this year has been particularly hard
as our residents left it later to turn
on their Heating
both contractors recovered in Q4 with
mir's finishing with 90
90.3 customer satisfaction which is a
good level of satisfaction
our contract with Gasco came to an end
on the 31st of March and our new
contractor BSW started on the 1st of
April
we've struggled to spend our capital
budget this year finishing on 54.34 and
this has been due to us not having key
contracts in place unfortunately some
contractors went into Administration
during this financial year and we've
struggled to reprocure them since
where we're seeing successes with our
void performance
we are steadily improving the turnaround
time and this is due to Stronger
contract management and ensuring we have
enough resources in place to deal with
the demand
we are also pleased with our income
collection as our arrears finish Q4 4.79
and this is a huge success for the team
who have steadily reduced arrears
through a very difficult operating
environment meaning arrears are now two
percent lower than when we transitioned
from East Kent housing in October 2020.
always like to finish on a high note
so if there are any questions
members do any comments or
questions you'd like to make on the
report
oh George
uh not a question but a comment and it's
more of a just I suppose a recognition
of the hard work that's gone on with all
this
um I think that the improvements across
the board in it generally are incredibly
impressive and actually
um the work that has been put into this
is is outstanding um and I just wanted
that to be put on record thank you chair
thank you Council cup anybody else
Council Austin can I just say a thank
you again for the glossary and for new
members if who aren't familiar with this
Annex five the document there the
Tennyson lease holds the services
performance report has a really useful
glossary and read learning would we
digest save it on your desktops whatever
because it's it's really really helpful
there is we in every in any area there
is so much technical terminology isn't
there and certainly I was at a complete
loss when I first looked at one of these
but the glossary makes such a difference
thank you
thank you anybody else
accounts to Wing I think when I'd like
to back up what you said I mean when you
think we've been through a pandemic
we're now in a cost of living crisis
until actually uh do the work you've
done has been pretty amazing really is
there any evidence that that some of our
tenants are really struggling because we
know they are and how are you managing
those those day-to-day struggles that
more and more people are sort of having
financially
foreign
yes we do have evidence of that and that
can be seen with the referrals that are
being made to our financial well-being
team and they work very closely with our
residents trying to give a holistic view
of how they can help them improve
um the way the way they live their
financial stability and mainly to
maintain their tenances and and be able
to pay their rent
we have a couple of resources to hand we
use the household support fund which
helped greatly through the last quarter
to help us be able to achieve that
result and we also look to make
referrals to other charitable
organizations for our residents where we
can
thank you
thank you anybody else remember oh
Council green yes
um
you say that there's there are more or
less steady decline in a number of homes
where action is taken to improve living
conditions
is this because there's less demand or
lack of resources
I'm sorry can you just clarify which
section you're seeing that in please no
I can't I'm afraid oh
I'm sorry read it again and let me see
if I can recall or remember you say
there's a more or less steady decline in
the number of homes where action taken
to improve living conditions
is this because there's a less demand
for it or is it due to lack of
resources
councilman I think I might be in the
next agenda item I think yeah
okay it's a couple of things I picked up
with uh Sally was um you said about the
overdue fire safety works because due to
uh no fire protection fire project
surveyor and there's I think there's an
issue recruitment is that underway again
the equivalent
um again I've moved a resource around in
the team to become the surveyor for fire
safety for so the fire safety works
and also there seems to be like the
backlog which you said about it for the
electrical safety inspections it's 260
still outstanding
but there's no gas
inspections outstanding well how come
the gas people can get in but the
electrical people can't
because I think it's due to no access I
think they're saying they can't get in
because
performance managing me as in to find
out the reasons we are okay perfect
yeah no um so by meeting with them every
week uh we push them to make sure that
they're that the contractors are
reporting Force accesses
um um no access accurately rather than
just leaving sites and we did that by
making them take a supervisor go out
with them to make sure that they were
being correct with that we've also now a
lot of the success is due to us
following the forced access process we
have with gas and we've replicated that
on the electrical safety and we can do
that in properties that are flattened
because if someone doesn't have their
electrical safety certificate in a flat
then of course they put that block at
risk
um but unfortunately we're limited with
being able to do that in in houses
well thank you
is anybody else got anything to say on
that agenda button
no so uh the recommendations are the
members of the overview and security
panel asked to note and scrutinize the
contents of the reports and Note and
scrutinize the contents of quarter three
and quarter four so are they noted
members noted thank you uh thank you
Sally for coming and presenting those
this evening giving up your time feel
free to stay or
know if you wish
so we're moving on to gender item number
seven
which is the chords three and quarter
four corporate performance report
and I miss Hannah Thorpe is presenting
that
thank you thank you very much uh chair
good evening councilors
um just to say so I don't have a little
name badge most of you know me I'm
Hannah and I am now the head of strategy
and transformation and corporate
performance reporting is part of my
remit uh the reason I want to share that
other than just being kind of helpful
um is because I will do my best to
answer any questions that come up this
evening my team is responsible for
collating the data and presenting it in
a format that is available for the
public and for councilors to scrutinize
and if you have technical questions in
relation to specific service areas I'll
do my best to answer them but it might
be that you have to bear with me and
we'll take it away and come back with an
answer afterwards and councilor green
I'm very happy if you want to put your
question to me again I might be able to
shine a little bit of light on your
question
um
because yeah I think that was one of the
indicators from this corporate
performance report so I'm going to start
with a bit of a general overview and the
reason for that is because some of you
have been through the corporate
performance reporting process before for
some other people it will be new so I'm
going to do a bit of a summary and then
I'm going to pick through some of the
highs and lows of the actual data that's
been presented to you this evening
so the overview Performance Management
is a key part of the corporate
governance process and adds value by
helping to ensure accountability of the
performance of the council services
against our corporate objectives which
I'm sure you all know or growth
environment and communities
this helps to encourage enhanced
accountability and continuous
Improvement of our services this report
tonight sets out as part of the
council's corporate performance process
39 key performance indicators which are
monitored to provide an indication of
how the council is performing
they don't look at every aspect of the
council services and the data that we
collect but they provide you with an
overview of the progress against our key
corporate priorities other data is of
course collected and it's monitored at a
service level
the data for most of the corporate
indicators is now available to view on
our website at any time
it's been agreed that a six-monthly
report of the council's corporate
performance will be shared with the
overview and scrutiny panel and the
cabinet to provide an opportunity to
more closely review the direction of
travel of our key service areas this
will allow sufficient time for actions
and issues to be resolved between
committee meetings and as the data for
the corporate performance indicators is
available to view on our website the
report presented this evening identifies
the data as at the end of quarter four
which is March 2023.
so the data is captured within a format
which aims to provide the public with
clear and easy to access information on
how our key services are performing we
also give you more detailed graphs
um which are there to provide a view of
the direction of travel for each of the
indicators it's worth also saying I'm
committed to continually improving the
way that we present this information and
to make sure it's as clear as possible
as an example for you within your
summary report there is a table
um which has got lots of pretty ticks
and Crosses which was fully intended to
be really transparent and to make it
kind of a simpler way of digesting the
information I need to point out when I
did put this within the report itself
that the ticks and the crosses correlate
to different data collection periods so
we we do the it's supposed to be like a
premier league table so you can see it
anytime how a particular indicator is
performing
um but obviously because we collect the
data sometimes weekly sometimes monthly
sometimes quarterly they don't actually
directly correlate when you look at them
in each kind of compare them and
contrast them to each other so whilst I
think the intention behind doing in that
way was absolutely right I'm not sure
that it's completely or that it's not
potentially misleading so I think
there's a way that we can refine that
and make sure that we're presenting it
in in a more kind of clear and concise
way
so in terms of the actual data itself
this quarter I just wanted to highlight
the fact you've got two sets of figures
that are missing out of the 39
indicators the first is the greenhouse
emissions we've got data that has been
compiled for 2019 2020 which could be
shared with you
um and we are just waiting on the final
report for 2021 and 2122 and it's been
quite complex to gather that because all
of the different
um the data is held within different
Services across the council so the
climate change officer that sits within
my area has been doing her best to try
to identify where all of those different
strands of data sit and I hope that
we're going to be in a position to be
able to share that with you the next
time we come to scrutiny
and the other data that's missing and I
know it's one of the ones that you will
have the keenest interest in and
guaranteed and that's the sites that are
free from litter
um so we have changed the way that we
record this data and we were quite
heavily criticized by the audit
um committee last in terms of the way
that we used to compile this data
because it was done by the team who
Suite the streets and kind of keep the
area clean they were kind of marking
their own homework we got through about
800 areas in a year
um and audit felt that it wasn't
necessarily the most kind of robust way
of monitoring the data and there wasn't
really a rationale as to kind of why
certain areas were collected so we have
now taken on board a more kind of
technological way of doing this and we
use cameras that are installed in our
vehicles that are out and about the
district we've compiled 6 700 photos
across the district we're mapping them
on an actual visual map and of those
we've managed to expect 1 200 sites they
are inspected by offices across the
council that don't just sit within the
operational Services team so there's
obviously less bias around that and we
still follow the same kind of formula in
terms of how that's recorded again
um I'll make sure that for the next time
that we come back to the scrutiny panel
that that data is presented back to you
and I think it's really important that
we do scrutinize that data because
you'll see later on we'll discuss the
fact that um public perception when it
comes to Street cleansing is not very
good and so I think it would be good to
marry that up that perception up then
with the reality of what the situation
is
so they're the two missing ones in terms
of our priority growth we've got six
indicators that we report against of
um of the six four have improved which
is around our wages
um that's wages across the district
license premises and our business rates
they're collected the areas that have
reduced in performance are around
unemployment and the number of food
businesses and it's worth just saying
five of those six indicators are what we
call contextual so that's not things
that are within the direct control of
the council but we actually think
they're really important in giving a bit
of a flavor of kind of what's going on
in the district which is why we include
them in the report
in terms of communities we've got 15
indicators that we report on 10 of those
have improved and five have reduced I'm
not going to go through each of them
individually because you can see the
report yourself but I do think it's
worth pulling out
um the number of households and
temporary accommodation it's at a record
high
um it's I'm sure that it comes as no
surprise to you it's something that Bob
Porter regularly briefs on in terms of
kind of what action the um the service
is taking to support that there's extra
resources that are going into trying to
improve that situation also and the
actual figure that's not included within
the report is actually 225 that's for
the quarter so it's even higher than the
annual rolling average suggests
um the number of affordable homes
completed has reduced slightly but I
thought it was worth sharing that the
March figure was at 81 and so we are
starting to see an improvement so that's
um showing that we're kind of heading in
the right direction and the other area I
was going to mention was around the HRA
Capital program but Sally has already
given you a really good explanation um
in relation to that
when it comes to the environment we
capture 12 indicators
um two of the data sets are missing as
I've explained five have improved and
five have reduced I particularly wanted
to highlight the figure around trees
because I think it is worthy of a
mention and there are 1043 trees and
slap things that were planted
um which is I think yeah it's a massive
Improvement on where we were before and
I think hopefully you're all aware of
that the projects that have sat behind
that
um our recycling rates
um it's showing us an area that's
improved I want to be completely
transparent with you it's still a
woefully low number and that is
something that we're really really aware
of and education Communications is going
to be a massive
um kind of action for us to try to do
what we can to encourage people to
continue to to recycle and to do to do
better at it frankly
um and I do think we should um just
identify the fact that our own waste
collection starts looking pretty healthy
and we generally are performing really
really well when it comes to making sure
the collecting everybody's rubbish
um and I have already alluded to the
fact when it comes to the reduced areas
of performance the street cleansing
satisfaction 26 I mean yeah that's it's
not a kind of
a confident note is it from the public
so I think that is definitely an area
that we want to unpick a little bit more
and understand what's sitting behind
that and work out again perception
versus reality and if there are
particular areas or
um places that are more of a problem
than just generally
um and then the final thing I didn't
explain but we capture something called
efficiency so every year when we ask our
residents to tell us how they'd like us
to be as a council they say please be
efficient
um so we capture some stats that kind of
hopefully identify that we are working
in an efficient way of the six four have
improved
um to have reduced
um it's worth saying although the number
of complaints is slightly better this
time
um the picture compared to now compared
to this time last year was actually
slightly worse so we are getting more
complaints and we're looking and behind
that to identify it and it is worth
saying that the data collection period
was around the time of the elections and
we were getting a lot of queries and
questions in relation to the voter ID
for example and so I do think that some
of the stats around that have been
influenced by that factor
um and I do also want to highlight the
fact that in the area that it's reduced
we've had an increased number of fois
um their rolling year average is 77.
it's worth just saying for March alone
we received 98. 98 FY it's staggeringly
high number to process and the team do a
phenomenal job at trying to coordinate
that and getting that out to all of the
different services but that is a really
really high number and also as a result
as you might expect it has then impacted
on the ability to respond within the
kind of the required time frame forgive
me
um but actually saying that 94 is still
really really good and those councilors
who are around kind of three four years
ago will know that Performance used to
be a lot worse than that so that's you
know Testament to the fact there's a new
and improved system in place to
um keep us on track
um that was as much of a summary I was
going to give I'm very happy to try my
best to answer any further questions
thank you
thank you Hannah and that's a very
comprehensive report I think everyone
will agree and I think there's some very
clear information there especially for
new councilors when you're going to get
asked by members of public what you know
how's this all work and you can refer to
this especially uh when it comes to bins
being emptied 99.8 because you're that
0.2 percent is going to fill your inbox
up you get you know
so members um we're asked to provide any
observations or comments to Cabinet who
will review this report at the meeting
on Thursday the 15th of June so
members any observations yes counselor
Wing uh observations I suppose they're
just
questions uh
it's about around planning appeals
remains very high is there any is there
any common indicators or themes around
which planning applications I'm on
planning around which planning
applications is it small builds is it
big builds is there any theme around
that you don't have to answer these
questions now I'm just sort of posing
temporary accommodation I know we're
looking for Solutions and I think the
loss of
you know we're looking for that that to
purchase that building which I hope will
help but it's still quite worrying that
we've got a significant number of people
particularly being placed out of
out of area sometimes vulnerable people
I know the housing team are doing all
they can so it's just
you know I think and the more success
you have the more maybe people come into
the area to and that's the same with the
homeless trees planted it's really great
to see 1043 trees planted and it's
really great to see that KCC have
actually planted a significant number of
Street trees as well I hope you don't
have two hot a summer so they die do we
know how many trees have been felled so
if we got an overall net gain of trees I
know if I fell a tree in my back Garden
hadn't got a tree and I wouldn't fill it
anyway but I suppose it's looking at
applications for filled trees so is it
have we got an offset also I'm really
quite interested in hedgerows as well
and our Hedges I did hear a bit of a
rumor that the Hedge on the western
Undercliff might be removed they are so
vital as in places for particularly
Birds to roost nest and I would hate to
see a whole series of Hedges removed
they're privy Hedges so I guess they
come to the end of their life and I know
the X-ray officer was looking at a plan
to plant a mixed Hedgerow in in front of
bushes that are past their sell by date
allow them to grow and then take the
hedgerows the original privet hedger out
a mixed Hedgerow would offer not only a
habitat but also food sources for
for birds so I'd be it'd be really
interesting to see if we've got some
sort of policy around keeping our
hedgerows sustaining what we've got and
trying to improve what we've got uh I
will be chaining myself to that hedger
if it ever attempted to come out uh
I'll carry on and then Street Scene I
use Street Scene quite regularly they do
a fabulous job really uh getting out
there and trying to tackle the odd
property that just consistently leaves
their seagull out and creates issues for
the the collectors so I'd like to
congratulate them but but I think we
really do have a cross than it some
serious properties that that need some
serious action taken against them I've
four years one in my ward we've got the
seagull bags from four being left out to
two to two so we've had some success uh
rubbish in central Harbor seems to be I
I constantly can thank the two guys that
are cleaning in in Ramsgate they do an
absolutely brilliant job and that I
believe that the street generally is
they're looking cleaner
dog poo is a big issue but what I would
say is that we have a particular issue
the day of collections so I took images
of the High Street at half past eight in
the morning I spoke to the two street
cleaners this morning and King Street
was worse than the High Street they'd
cleaned it all up but it was serious it
would have taken them an hour to just to
deal with that
so could a solution be on those bin days
for the street cleaners to just follow
the bin men round they've been people
round paragon's another one on a Monday
Paragon it's a main route in and it's
constantly covered in rubbish and it
makes me embarrassed and sometimes I go
around and clicked it all up myself if
I've got time because I don't want
visits visitors to think we're worse
than we actually are
they're just and graffiti is another big
one graffiti is massively on the
increase I've reported some in in my in
in our world particularly in prominent
positions minor Works were brilliant on
the West Cliff Promenade on a private
property they actually got out and did
it once we got permission because it was
in a main area and there was masses of
it so I'm wondering if we could maybe
have a bit of a Target on graffiti I
don't know what it's like across across
than it but it's it's pretty bad in in
central Harbor
um
so they're just observations really but
but thank you I think things are
improving
yep okay just so actually I captured all
of that did you not as eloquently said
it but enough to be able to feedback to
relevant people so if there's anything
that I can kind of get to come back to
you then I will but just to say and I'm
so sorry this is my error in terms of
the trees planted style it is the net
tree the next figure that is within the
report I can just give you a quick
overview so it's I'm not quite sure how
the stats are compiled um but we do have
standard trees planted by TDC then
standard trees planted by the community
on our land trees removed by us and then
we have a net trees planted figure for
our land and then saplings planted etc
etc yeah so actually if that was an area
that for example maybe next time you
wanted to particularly focus on I could
provide a bit more details yeah
um reflection of that but yeah my
apologies thank you thank you for that
thanks Council and cancer Curry
sure thanks for your report Hannah lots
of data there to get through a few
things stood out 141 homeless cases
prevented that's that's fantastic yeah
the beans collected that would surprise
a lot of people you know get it on for
uh the recycling is is too low I think
we all know that 34 we we desperately
need to get that figure up
and just one question really I'm not
sure whether you'll be able to answer
this one but it roughly I just wondered
where the um the TVC Greenhouse
emissions where where do we sort of get
that data from uh roughly
so it's across our estate so mainly the
buildings that we're responsible for
um so that would be like this office for
example then any other buildings that
we're responsible for
um I'm not sure whether I think it also
does include our vehicle emissions as
well
um again Hannah Scott if she was here
would give you a really good answer on
that but again in maybe in the summary I
can provide a bit more information in
terms of where that data comes is
captured and it might even be the
members one a bit more of a detailed
response anyway given that we have got
some missing figures so it'd be good
just to give a bit of a bit you know a
better picture around that okay thank
you Council Davis
and it's pleasing that there seems to be
a general upward Trend mine was a Darth
question though from Becky actually you
mentioned the Hedge on the you said the
Western Undercliff do you mean along the
Promenade the one by the greens yeah
that
that would be going yeah that it might
be going okay it's in our Ward and we
hadn't seen anything about it but we'll
keep an eye on it
tell us them all
yes thank you and thank you for your
presentation Hannah
um you mentioned about street cleaning
and it's not particularly good and I
think everyone knows it's not very good
um I'll be going to review how we're
working at the moment because we seem to
centralize the street cleaners in
certain areas and other areas fail
dismally and we've now got residents
trying to do it the other issue partly
with that is that we've had some Street
bins removed
uh under whoever's decision but people
still put their rubbish where those bins
were
um and those bins are sanctusan they
were there for a reason we took them
away uh naively and that's caused and
impacted and made the streets even
filthier than they should be
um so is there going to be a review for
that
um and if so can we be involved in that
because especially in my ward
um it's absolutely awful and I haven't
seen a street cleaner for months and it
only seems to be sort of like targeted
when it gets really really bad but we
get berated because it's always filthy
and they used to be there and it used to
be tidy but the standard has dropped and
I appreciate we're having task force
hitting areas but we really need the
street bins back where they were so
people can put the rubbish in those bins
thank you
yep so I think it's a really important
point of clarification the 26 that I
talk about when it when it comes to kind
of being low levels of performance
that's around public perception of how
clean the streets are that's not a
percentage of how effective the team are
being I think that's a really important
distinction to make the team worked
really really really hard it has been an
area of focus
um it's um we've got these new Street
cleansing standards that have been
developed if they haven't been published
on the website yet that they will be
imminently and that explains exactly how
the council's approach is in terms of
when we target certain areas how many
people are working in different places
um the response rates you can expect in
terms of dealing with particular issues
this really really detailed and helpful
information what I'm going to do and
this is obviously within my conversarius
I need to ask to make sure he's happy
but it feels to me that it would be
really helpful perhaps if he and or Mark
Greening could come and give a
presentation in relation to some of the
activity that's gone on around Street
cleansing because it has been an area
that has been targeted and focused on
and I think it would be really helpful
especially if members of the public are
going to be seeing these new standards
then you know you'd probably like to be
a little bit more aware of the detail
behind that before that goes out to The
Wider public but I think it's really
important to say that low percentage
that I'm talking about that is the
public perception which is why it's
really important that we marry that up
then with our inspections all the
different sites just to get a better
flavor of how kind of bad it is and I
agree with you the public perception are
people people never post a picture on
Facebook of a clean Street you know so
that you know the public perception is
can be a bit skipped out Council yes
thank you Anna um I think one of the
aspects of it is is about the community
and having a street clean or seeing
people doing that is part of that
Community aspect and people are missing
that and therefore the perception is
that work isn't being done and we need
to promote that and and and and be
Advocates and
um shining lights to actually get that
message out which I don't think we're
doing
um but there still is a trend where they
are particularly bad and we just need to
focus on that as well but I take on
board what you said
anybody else would like to make any
comments
uh
Helen sorry just wanted to beg your
Indulgence and just to reassure
counselor more
um Street cleansing is something that we
talked about specifically as cabinet
over the past week so that is something
that we will be focusing on in terms of
strategy thank you thanks for uh
something I picked up on was the I mean
the empty homes continues to rise
because again looking at the graph and I
don't think that's the correct figure I
think it's a lot higher than that I
think that's there's a there's a there's
a way they work out the figures I think
about how long they've been emptying I
think it gives that figure and I think
that it could be a lot higher than that
is there any research happening on find
that via the reason why those empty
homes the numbers going up do you know
if there's any research
that's something I would have to take
away and get an answer and come back on
that if that's okay and also picked up I
think you did say that the um the
affordable homes completions have gone
up but I think people would be shocked
to say see it's only 34. when we see all
those houses at Westwood going up but I
know you say it's now 81 but when we got
a 30 affordable homes Target 34 out of
543 is incredibly low so that's just
canceling
uh
domes also also include second homes or
even third homes so that
I know I got the impression it was
something that's been empty for over 12
months it's registered as a empty
property a second home is in class is an
empty property if they pay in the
forecast yeah yeah
anybody else would like to say anything
oh okay so yeah sure thank you no sorry
um I did just find that it's them in
terms of the empty homes including all
homes that have been empty for more than
six months
okay thank you members uh right so we're
asked to note the reports and obviously
your comments will go to a cabinet on
the 15th of June okay thank you kind of
for that for coming along this evening
and give us that report excellent uh
that concludes the business for
tonight's meeting I declare this meeting
closed at
8 22. I thank you all for coming and the
live stream for the meeting we're now in
thanks for going easy on me
yeah